ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen die
Kriege der Zukunft werden durch
künstliche Intelligenz entschieden also
durch KI sagen Leute die sich damit
auskennen wobei eigentlich ist es heute
schon so dass KI in Kriegen eine ganz
entscheidende Rolle spielt zum Beispiel
ganz aktuell in der Ukraine
hier wird künstliche Intelligenz schon
jetzt genutzt um sich gegen den
russischen Angriff zu verteidigen da
geht es zum Beispiel um die Steuerung
von Drohnen oder die Auswertungen von
Satellitenbildern aus verschiedenen
Quellen um sich ein Lagebild zu
verschaffen und Einsätze besser planen
zu können
wie verändert KI unsere Welt und auch
unsere Kriege und gibt es die Gefahr
dass die Waffensysteme selbst irgendwann
die Kontrolle übernehmen genau damit
beschäftigt sich heute unter anderem der
un-weltsicherheitsrat zum ersten Mal in
New York wir sprechen darüber gleich mit
unserem Korrespondenten was meint ihr
schreibt uns eure Fragen und Kommentare
gerne in die Kommentare oder an die
eingeblendete E-Mail-Adresse wenn ihr
die App nutzt ich gebe die Fragen sehr
gerne weiter an unseren heutigen
Gesprächspartner da ist er Professor
Gary Schal vom gids Think Tank der
Bundeswehr in Hamburg guten Abend Herr
Professor Schal
guten Abend
sie beschäftigen sich mit künstlicher
Intelligenz mit Drohnen und Drohnen
Abwehr und sie leiten verschiedene
Projekte in Zusammenarbeit auch mit der
Rüstungsindustrie in der es um die
Verwendung von KI auch für das Militär
geht Herr Professor Schall lassen Sie
uns gleich das Beispiel vom Eingang
nehmen Satellitenbilder die ausgewertet
werden um eine Lage einzuschätzen wie
lange braucht der Mensch und wie lange
braucht dafür die KI
die Frage ist nicht wie lange braucht
der Menschen wie lange braucht die KI
die KI in der Regel natürlich sehr viel
schneller sondern was kann die KI sehen
was vielleicht ein Mensch nicht sehen
kann ein Mensch hat Erfahrung hat
Hintergrund kann vielleicht auf Basis
von bisherigen Situationen Dinge
prognostizieren KI kann aufgrund der
Möglichkeit sehr unterschiedliche Daten
zusammenzunehmen andere Entscheidungen
treffen als Menschen das tun würden und
vor dem Hintergrund hat die Nutzung von
künstlich Intelligenz ein
Überraschungsmoment das quasi demjenigen
der sie nutzt ein Vorteil geben kann
weil er zu taktischen Entscheidungen
kommt auf die ein Mensch vielleicht
nicht gekommen wäre insofern zweigeteilt
sie ist schneller und sie führt zu
anderen Entscheidungen ob sie dann
besser ist müsste man erstmal ein
Simulationen überprüfen aber sie hat
einen Vorteil den Überraschungsmoment
nun fragt ihr ein User über Youtube oder
stellt zumindest fest dass die KI nur so
intelligent sein kann wie die die sie
programmieren
das ist ein ganz typischer Hinweis aber
es gibt ja ganz unterschiedliche Formen
von künstlicher Intelligenz und es gibt
künstliche Intelligenzen die anhand von
sozusagen Sensordaten real world Daten
trainiert werden das sind dann
typischerweise solche die mit neuronalen
Netzen arbeiten und dann gibt es solche
die Spielen gegen sich selbst spielen
auf Basis bestimmter Regeln das kennen
wir das kennen wir zum Beispiel aus go
alphago war ein schönes Beispiel dafür
und diese Form von künstliche
Intelligenz wird nicht programmiert
sondern man hat Lust die
Rahmenbedingungen und Situationen werden
so häufig
iteriert bis man zu
taktischen entscheidungssequenzen kommt
die gut sind und insofern ist das
Argument mit dem Programmieren geht
nicht für alle Kies sondern bloß für
bestimmte Kios und gerade diese sich
selbst anlernen denn spielenden Kies
sind sehr innovativ wir sind jetzt hier
gerade
ki-roboter im Einsatz sind
künstliche Intelligenzen die besseren
Soldaten oder möglicherweise die
besseren Generäle
interessante Frage weil was heißt hier
besser
wir haben zum Glück die Genfer
Konvention unterzeichnet das heißt es
gibt bestimmte Grenzen dessen was wir
wollen und was wir tun dürfen und das
heißt gute Soldaten oder gute Generäle
sind diejenigen die sich an die Ethik
des Krieges halten wenn in der notwendig
ist das ist bei künstliche Intelligenz
nicht notwendigerweise der Fall also je
nachdem welche Grenzen die KI hat
verhandeln kann sie besser oder
schlechter sein erster Punkt
zweiter Punkt ist das was wir von
menschlichem Handeln kennt dass man
Angst hat dass man
müde wird dass man vielleicht
entscheidungsmühle wird und ähnliches
das trifft natürlich auf künstliche
Intelligenz nicht zu und insofern gibt
es vielleicht auch bestimmte Entscheid
ungen die aufgrund von über Erschöpfung
oder ähnliches passieren dort auch nicht
also was sind die Parameter mit denen
sie bestimmen was ist ein guter oder ein
schlechter Soldat was ist eine gute oder
ein schlechte Entscheidung denn wir sind
nicht dort zu sagen jeder Sieg ist ein
guter Sieg unabhängig von Mitteln die
wir dafür einsetzen und vor dem
Hintergrund lassen uns über die Mittel
sprechen das was wir bereits sind
sozusagen zu geben über die Ethik und
dann fragen wir noch mal was kann KI
dazu leisten solche Ziele zu erreichen
ich freue mich darüber mit ihnen über
die Ethik zu sprechen sie sind auch
Philosoph und das sind ja auch viele
philosophische Fragen die da dahinter
stehen die man sich dann stellen muss
dazu an dieser Stelle noch ein Kommentar
von einem User Thomas Rabenstein sagt
über YouTube eine KI ist nicht schlecht
invasiv oder bösartig sondern sie ist so
wie wir sie erschaffen sie kann Leben
retten oder zerstören es liegt an uns
welchen Weg wir wählen ich würde gerne
die ethik-diskussion allerdings noch ein
bisschen nach nach hinten schieben
inhaltlich hier in unserem Stream
sondern erstmal darüber sprechen was KI
denn im Krieg in der Kriegsführung so
überhaupt alles kann und wie sie
eingesetzt wird können Sie da aktuell
ein paar Beispiele geben auch mit Blick
auf die Bundeswehr wo da schon KI im
Einsatz ist
ich würde ich würde sogar noch erweitern
und gleich quasi in Richtung Ukraine
schauen
es ist so dass so dass dort so wohl auf
ukrainischer wie auch auf russischer
Seite künstliche Intelligenz zum Einsatz
kommt wobei künstliche Intelligenz jetzt
für mich bedeutet jede Form der
algorithmischen Aufarbeitung von Daten
bei denen das Ergebnis so wirkt als wenn
ein Mensch klug handeln würde ja also
das als vor Definition und vor diesem
Hintergrund haben wir es in dem letzten
500 Tagen erlebt dass Systeme die zuvor
sagen diesmal analog waren digital
hochgerüstet oder aufgerüstet wurden und
damit wirkungs effektiver wurden das
bezieht sich jetzt auf unterschiedliche
Dinge das Drohnen quasi
KI nutzen quasi automatisch Ziele zu
finden zu identifizieren das wissen wir
dann sehr relevant für die Ukraine und
den die Entwicklung des Krieges dort ist
die Auswertung von internations
Informationen also von Bildmaterial von
abgehörten Funksprüchen oder ähnliches
das sind so viele Informationen das
können Menschen nicht machen dort kommt
künstliche Intelligenz natürlich zum
Zuge aber auch bei einer anderen Frage
nämlich bei Artillerie und
feuerleitsystemen kommt künstliche
Intelligenzen Zuge das heißt dort wo
früher zu Beginn des Krieges zwischen
einem Befehl und der Ausrichtung
vielleicht 30 Minuten vergingen Vergehen
jetzt mit Hilfe der Nutzung von
künstliche Intelligenz zwei drei Minuten
und sehr wichtig für die Ukraine das
solche künstlichen intelligenzsysteme
auch die Munition effizienter und
effektiver nutzen sehr wichtig das heißt
wir haben künstliche Intelligenz überall
sie ist
kein Game changer was sie auf beiden
Seiten benutzt wird aber ein Game
Veränderer weil tatsächlich die Seite
die es nicht nutzen würde meines
Erachtens relativ schnell verlieren
würde die Seite die sie nutzt aber nicht
notwendigerweise gewinnt
sie haben einige Beispiele genannt was
die Ukraine angeht zum Beispiel Drohnen
zum Beispiel die Munition
um den Ansatz von Munition ich möchte
gern ein Beispiel noch herausgreifen mit
dem sie auch als forschender beschäftigt
sind denn es gibt eine Frage dazu im
Chat ein User fragt kann KI schon für
Kriegsszenarien sogenannte war Games
herangezogen werden um die bestmögliche
Taktik zu entwickeln und wenn ich das
jetzt richtig verstehe dann ist Ihre
Antwort darauf ja und sie heißt
ghostplay ja die Antwort lautet
tatsächlich Cosplay wir haben ein
Forschungsprojekt in dem eine KI der
dritten Welle genutzt wird um
drohnenschwärme also angreifen
für alle die dies nicht wissen die
dritte Welle können Sie die ganz kurz
erklären bitte das mache ich sehr gerne
zweite Welle KI ist so typischerweise
identifiziert mit Bilderkennung und
ähnlichem also quasi statische Dinge die
wiedererkannt werden musste Erkennung
KI der dritten Welle bedeutet dass man
Kontext sensitiv ist die KI reagiert auf
dem Kontext indem sie genutzt wird und
sie ist das wird ganz wichtig
sensitiv für die Konsequenzen über die
Zeit ich gebe ihnen kleines Beispiel es
könnte ja sein dass wir in diesem
Augenblick ein taktischen Vorteil haben
indem wir ein aktives Radar nutzen wir
sehen aber dass wenn wir das aktive
Radon nutzen die uns exponieren und dann
vielleicht dieses Radar zerstört wird
wenn man sichtbar gemacht wird das heißt
man muss in die Tiefe gehen und schauen
wie unterschiedliche Handlungen auf
unserer Seite über die Zeit hinweg
unterschiedliche Handlungen bei dem
Gegner provozieren das wäre dann quasi
diese tiefen Staffelung und das
kennzeichnet künstliche Intelligenz der
dritten Welle und genau das wird für
morgen auch genutzt weil man hiermit
natürlich unterschiedliche Samsung
strategische operative Abfolgen sehr gut
simulieren kann und eben nicht nur zu
einem Zeitpunkt sondern über mehrere
entscheidungsfrequenzen Tage Wochen
hinweg wenn man einfach die Simulation
lange genug laufen lässt mit anderen
Worten ja es sind
entscheidungsunterstützungssysteme sie
können aber auch in der konkreten
Entscheidungssituation auf dem Kampffeld
genutzt werden dann lassen Sie uns ein
bisschen über Gefahren sprechen hier
fragt ein User ist es nicht nur eine
Frage der Zeit bis strukturell
problematische Staaten gnadenlose KI
Kriegswaffen einsetzen und wie können
die angegriffenen dann noch gut werhaft
sein also die Frage die grundsätzlicher
dahinter steht ist die Gefahr eines
Wettrüstens gegeben durch KI
meine Antwort lautete vorhin wer KI
nicht nutzt verliert wer KI nutzt wird
nicht zwangsläufig gewinnen aber er hat
bessere Chancen insofern sind wir
natürlich in einem Wettrüsten in Bezug
auf die Frage der
Weiterentwicklung von KI und der
Implementation von KI wichtig ist aber
KI selber und alleine ist nicht
kriegsentscheidend wenn wir uns die
Ukraine anschauen sehen wir es geht auch
um die Verfügbarkeit von wirkungsmitteln
Munition zum Beispiel und es geht um das
was wir in ghostplay Ökosystemen nennen
das heißt künstliche Intelligenz
benötigt Sensordaten künstliche
Intelligenz benötigt das Zusammenführen
von Sensordaten benötigt sozusagen dann
auch die Verbindung zu den Soldaten die
dann vor Ort sich bewegen müssen oder zu
entsprechenden wirkungsmitteln und oder
zu Radar es ist also letzten Endes ein
Baustein in einem sehr komplexen System
das nur wenn es sozusagen komplex und
systemisch gedacht wird wirklich
wirkungsüberlegenheiten dass die
Bundeswehr erzielen kann also KI alleine
ist kein gamechanger aber KI in einem
Ökosystem das entsprechend aufgebaut
wird kannst du wirkungsüberlegenheit
führen
okay dann schauen wir mal darauf wie die
Weltgemeinschaft sich sortiert in dieser
Frage denn zum ersten Mal hat sich wie
gesagt der
UN-Sicherheitsrat damit beschäftigt und
wir sprechen gleich weiter lieber
Professor Schall werfen aber einen
kurzen Blick in die USA zu unserem
korresponden matthäusern vorher fast und
Silke Petersen zusammen wie sich in New
York die Mitglieder des Sicherheitsrates
damit heute beschäftigt haben
was wenn Maschinen schlauer werden als
wir Menschen wie sicher ist die Welt
dann noch im UN-Sicherheitsrat geht es
um die Gefahren künstlicher Intelligenz
und um ihren Nutzen
künstliche Intelligenz wird alles im
menschlichen Leben verändern
fundamentale Entdeckung in der Medizin
könnten vor der Tür stehen aber KI kann
globale strategische Stabilität
verbessern oder stören
auf politische Destabilisierung Zielen
künstlich erzeugte Videos wieder
Zusammenbruch des französischen
Präsidenten
oder auch Putin der hier angeblich auf
Englisch der US-Bevölkerung droht
wahr oder Fake gefährliche Konfusion ist
meistens global Experten halten deshalb
eine Art Aufsichtsbehörde etwa nach dem
Vorbild der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde für nötig
wir müssen uns künstliche Intelligenz
globaler nähern und nicht nur beherrscht
durch die Sicherheitsratsmitglieder oder
die G7 wir müssen alle Länder weltweit
einschließen
Manipulationen sind überall denkbar bei
sensiblen Infrastrukturen oder bei der
Kriegsführung KI könnte den
Rüstungswettlauf befeuern auch im
zivilenbereich gibt es eine Gefahr eines
wettlaufes der dazu führen könnte dass
noch nicht ganz ausgereifte ki-systeme
in die Welt gebracht werden und auch das
kann die stabilisierend sein London lädt
im Herbst zu einer globalen ki-konferenz
ein den tech-konzern allein wollen sie
die Verantwortung nicht überlassen
tja eine ki-konferenz in London jetzt
aber heute erstmal zwei verschiedene
Sitzungen in den USA MRT wissen ist
unser Korrespondent dort in Washington
bist du uns zugeschaltet und dort gab es
heute ein treffendes
streitkräfteausschusses des
US-Kongresses darüber sprechen wir
gleich aber erst über den
Weltsicherheitsrat denn wir wollen
natürlich hier aus Deutschland auch den
Blick aufs große Ganze sehen ähm
inwiefern ist das denn heute auch so
dramatisiert worden wie wir das in der
Vergangenheit von UN-Generalsekretär
gutäre schon gehört haben der hat ja die
Gefahr durch KI quasi mit der Gefahr
eines Atomkriegs verglichen
ja genau das hat er heute wieder gemacht
also dieses Treffen des
Weltsicherheitsrates zu diesem Thema ist
zustande gekommen durch mehrere
Mitgliedstaaten die gedrängelt haben
darunter auch Großbritannien weil sie
eben sagen das ist ein Thema das müssen
wir jetzt endlich mal bearbeiten und der
Generalsekretär uterisch hat dann eben
auch die einleitende Rede gehalten er
hat einerseits gesagt natürlich birgt ai
auch eine riesige Chance für die Welt
die Entwicklung dieser Welt auch
voranzubringen und hat eine ganze Menge
von Beispielen im positiven Sinne auch
genannt aber hat dann ein eher düsteres
Bild gezeichnet welche Gefahren welche
Risiken gibt es allen voran wenn zum
Beispiel eben durch den Missbrauch von
künstlicher Intelligenz durch kriminelle
durch Terroristen aber auch durch
Staaten am Ende tot und Zerstörung
Trauma und psychische Dramen ausgelöst
werden was durchaus möglich ist auch da
hat er eine ganze Reihe von Beispielen
genannt und er hat dann eben gesagt wir
brauchen dringend eine Regulierung der
begrüßt den Vorschlag den einige Staaten
gemacht haben nämlich sowas zu schaffen
wie eine neue internationale
Aufsichtsbehörde wir kennen so etwas aus
dem Bereich der Atomwaffen das ist die
Internationale
Atomenergiebehörde in Wien die
kontrolliert oder überwacht im Grunde
genommen wie die Staaten der Welt eben
mit Nuklearenergie umgehen solch ein
Gremium könnte auch geschaffen werden
als Behörde der Vereinten Nationen so
ist die Idee es könnte bestimmte Regeln
mit entwickeln und weiterentwickeln aber
eben auch kontrollieren und überwachen
und der wenn Generalsekretär hat
vorgeschlagen dass er bis zum Jahresende
jetzt einen Beratungsgremium Tagen lässt
dass dann eben Ideen entwickelt wie man
tatsächlich
international Regeln entwickeln und auch
durchsetzen kann und dann danach im
nächsten Jahr möglicherweise spätestens
im übernächsten Jahr soll dann eben auch
entschieden werden ob so eine unbehörde
sinnvoll ist nach den Wortbeiträgen der
anderen Beteiligten im
Weltsicherheitsrat zu urteilen brennt es
ihnen auch unter den Nägeln es gab im
Grunde genommen keinen der gesagt hat
kommt nicht den Frage sondern alle haben
gesagt wir müssen schauen welche
positiven Auswirkungen von künstlicher
Intelligenz wir fördern und unterstützen
können während wir gleichzeitig alles
daran setzen müssen auf internationaler
Ebene Vereinbarungen zu treffen um den
Missbrauch dieser Technologie auch zu
verhindern und gleichzeitig ist das ja
ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit egal ob man
sich jetzt den Weltsicherheitsrat
anguckt und das was dort an Regularien
geschaffen werden soll sondern auch was
die was die die Arbeit der
Ausschussmitglieder im US-Kongress
angeht was war denn da heute der Tenor
hat man da das Gefühl auch hinterher zu
laufen oder hat man da das Gefühl noch
so schnell zu sein dass man Regeln
aufstellen kann die dann tatsächlich
auch anwendbar sind
ja es war faszinierend das zu beobachten
die Abgeordneten hatten sich Experten
eingeladen und eine Abgeordnete sagte
dann wir sind ja in der Situation wo wir
eine Art Bewunderung für dieses Problem
haben dass ein Riesenproblem eben auch
ist diese künstliche Intelligenz weil
sie überhaupt nicht reguliert wird weder
im kommerziellen im privaten Bereich
noch eben im regierungsbereich und vor
diesem Hintergrund im streitekräfte
Ausstoß war natürlich in erster Linie
das Thema müssen die Vereinigten Staaten
massiv in künstliche Intelligenz eben
auch investieren um dann in Krisen und
Konflikten im Kriegsfall in der Lage zu
sein gegen andere Staaten gegen zu
halten die eben auch künstliche
Intelligenz nutzen allen voran
möglicherweise autoritäre Regime wie
China und Russland und auch dabei
interessant zu sehen was die Experten
sagen einige die natürlich auch waren
wir brauchen regeln wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass beispielsweise wenn
Waffensysteme autonome Waffen getestet
werden das die ethischen
Rahmenbedingungen auf die wir uns als
Demokratien verpflichten mit
berücksichtigt werden also dass man
sicherstellt dass ein Mensch am Ende
immer noch die Kontrolle hat dass man
einen Gerät oder eine KI auch
ausschalten kann am Ende aber ein
anderer Experte der dann eben sagt das
ist alles schön und gut und alles
wunderbar aber es drängt die Zeit wir
dürfen auf keinen Fall
die Zeit zu sehr verschwenden auf
regelschaffen sondern wir müssen diese
Entwicklung vorantreiben weil wir sonst
eben auch bei möglichen militärischen
Konflikten ins Hintertreffen geraten und
tatsächlich ist das Pentagon hier in den
USA in den letzten Jahren schon massiv
dabei für eben mögliche Kriegsszenarien
künstliche Intelligenz weiter zu
entwickeln
entsprechend auch in dieses Thema
einzubauen und da sind im nächsten
Haushalt im Militärhaushalt der
Vereinigten Staaten allein knapp drei
Milliarden Dollar vorgesehen die eben
diese Entwicklung vorantreiben sollen
lass uns das an der Stelle noch mal
vertiefen ein User namens Thomas Beyer
schreibt über Facebook in Zukunft werden
wohl kaum noch Krieger auf dem
Schlachtfeld gewonnen hier werden doch
Soldaten nur noch zum Spielball der
Technik und derer welche diese nutzen
und bedienen das ist sozusagen die
Schattenseite viele sagen ja aber auch
mit KI schützen wir unsere Soldaten
besser wir können ihre Überlebenschancen
in den Einsätzen steigern und es ist
deshalb wichtig dass wir im Militär in
KI investieren diese Investitionen
werden offenbar getätigt in den USA hast
du gesagt was tut denn die US-Armee
konkret
ja die US-Armee nicht nur die Armee
sondern alle Truppengattungen die haben
ein Programm das nennt sich Jersey 2 das
heißt im Grunde genommen joint all
Domain command and control und das ist
ein System das quasi künstliche
Intelligenz mit einbindet und dafür
sorgen soll dass in einem Kriegsszenario
alle Informationen die man über Sensoren
über Aufklärungsmöglichkeiten über
Satelliten über auch menschliche Quellen
alles was an Informationen über die Lage
verfügbar ist über die Aufstellung des
Feindes über das was er an Material an
Technologie an Soldaten im Feld hat all
diese Informationen zusammenführt und
dann mit Hilfe von künstlicher
Intelligenz auswertet um möglichst
schnell daraus abzuleiten wie man am
besten eben darauf reagiert
möglicherweise bis zu dem Punkt wo Feuer
Befehle also wirklich Abschuss Befehle
an amerikanische Waffensystemen von
diesem System von dieser künstlichen
Intelligenz gegeben werden könnten und
sehen die Regeln hier in den USA vor
dass darf am Ende so dann nicht
passieren weil immer noch muss der
Mensch ich sag mal der General derjenige
sein der diese Entscheidung fällt oder
der gefechtsfeldkommandeur aber es
entsteht ja ein unglaublicher Druck wenn
man in einer schwierigen militärischen
Situation ist man hat all diese Daten
die künstliche Intelligenz schlägt vor
bestimmte Ziele dann eben auch
anzugreifen dann passiert das alles in
Sekunden möglicherweise in Bruchteilen
von Sekunden viel schneller als ein
Mensch möglicherweise entscheiden wird
und angesichts der Tatsache dass es
mittlerweile überall Raketen gibt also
Raketen die mit mehrfacher
Schallgeschwindigkeit fliegen die also
so schnell sind dass ein Mensch kaum
Zeit hat die Entscheidung zu fällen kann
es eben einen Punkt geben wo dann die
Maschine die künstliche Intelligenz man
nennt es hier der robotergeneral dann
die Entscheid auffällt und das gleiche
machen eben ja nicht nur die Vereinigten
Staaten es macht auch China da heißt das
Programm ich habe mir das mal
aufgeschrieben MDP W also Multi Domain
precision Warfare also eben auch ein
über alle
Waffengattungen reichende
präzisionskriegsführung gewissermaßen
das ist das gleiche also es wird alles
miteinander vernetzt was an
Informationen vorhanden ist und man
stelle sich das Szenario vor man ist
dann in einem Krieg auf beiden Seiten
sind die Computer die künstlichen
Intelligenzen am Berg und am Ende kommt
es eigentlich nur noch darauf an wer
löst schneller dann den Gegenschlag aus
um etwas zu verhindern und da stellen
sich automatisch große Fragen nicht nur
die moralischen sondern auch die Frage
stimmt denn die Informationen die der
Entscheidung der KI zugrunde liegt hat
der Gegner möglicherweise seine eigenen
Daten so manipuliert dass man in die
Irre geführt wird also eine ganze Anzahl
von Problemen und Frage Stellungen die
dann existieren und die größte Sorge ist
natürlich dass am Ende diese Vernetzung
auch erfolgt mit Atomwaffen dass wir
also über so eine Eskalation der
Maschinen in eine nuklear Krieg und
damit in den Endzeit-Szenario geraten
könnten
viele offene Fragen Elmar vielen Dank
für deine Einschätzungen aus den USA und
das Teilen auch hier viele Userinnen und
User diese Gedanken einer fragt wie kann
gewährleistet werden dass KI gesteuerte
Systeme nicht vom Feind gehackt und
übernommen werden genau das hast du ja
gerade angesprochen und Franka Laven
sagt über Facebook internationale
Regulierung ist dringend erforderlich
wie wir hören ist das aber noch ein
weiter Weg zu gehen vielen Dank Elmar
Thesen für den Moment nach Washington
und damit kommen wir wieder zurück zu
Professor Gary Schal von der Denkfabrik
der Bundeswehr in Hamburg und eine ein
Wort möchte ich gerne aus Washington mit
zu Ihnen bringen nach Hamburg nämlich
dass das
robotergenerals wie weit sind wir denn
hier in Deutschland von so etwas
entfernt
in Deutschland sind wir komplett weit
also in der Bundeswehr sind hier
komplett weiter von entfernt bei
vollkommen klar ist dass die
Verantwortung bei einem menschenliegen
muss wir haben KI
entscheidungsunterstützungssysteme die
werden auch in Zukunft wichtiger werden
und diese KI
entscheidungsunterstützungssysteme
leisten das was vorhin aus Washington
berichtet wurde nämlich Daten so schnell
aufzuarbeiten dass man dann als Mensch
mehr Zeit hat um informierte ethisch
moralisch informierte Entscheidungen zu
treffen insofern kann KI genau das
Gegenteil von dem bringen was manche
Kritiker befürchten nämlich Zeit
gewinnen damit man den Menschen wieder
reinbringen kann in dieser oder oder ähm
also es ist ein ambivalenter Prozess in
Bezug auf die Frage was machen wir mit
Waffen die so schnell sind dass man als
Mensch wieso keine Chance mehr hätte
darauf zu reagieren das sind nur eine
bestimmte Anzahl von Waffen sind
hyperschallwaffen bei dem man ganz
sicher entsprechen
automatisierte Systeme braucht bei denen
aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit von
Kollateralschäden ausgesprochen gering
ist wir haben es damit anderen
wirkmitteln zu tun Drohnen oder
ähnliches die zum Beispiel in Gebieten
im Einsatz sind in denen es Zivilisten
gibt oder ähnliches dort sind
potenzielle konzentralschäden so groß
dass man sich natürlich Sorgen machen
muss darüber ob man dort solche Systeme
in welchem Autonomie gerade eingesetzt
werden will also mein Vorschlag wir
schauen was sind die konkreten sozusagen
Nutzungsszenarien und nehmen dann von
dort aus so Risiken Matrixen
Berechnungen vor und von dort aus
weiterzukommen
dann lassen Sie uns bei dem Beispiel der
Drohnen gerade mal bleiben wir haben
einen Blick darauf geworfen welche Rolle
künstliche Intelligenz in Zusammenhang
mit Drohnen spielen kann und das schauen
wir uns gemeinsam an
schon seit einiger Zeit haben Hersteller
ihr Verteidigungs Arsenal an die
Bedrohung angepasst so genannte Jammer
unterbrechen die elektronische Steuerung
ein gezielter Schuss mit speziellen
Gewehren das war's
Schwärme und größere Drohnen werden per
Radar und optischer Aufklärung erfasst
künstliche Intelligenz analysiert per
Mustererkennung anfliegende Objekte in
Sekundenbruchteilen
Mantis etwa ein Flugabwehrsystem der
Bundeswehr feuertausend Schuss in der
Minute ab und berechnet in Millisekunden
wann die intelligente Munition vor dem
Eindringling am effektivsten explodiert
kurz vor dem Ziel setzt die Granate
unzählige splitterfrei ein Durchkommen
unmöglich
die Abwehrwaffe der Zukunft ist schon in
der Erprobung ebenfalls per KI
unterstützt entscheiden
laserstrahlkanonen welches Ziel Sie
zuerst und dann gemeinsam attackieren
Vorteil Abwehr also wohl kaum denn auch
die drohnenentwicklung geht weiter mit
mehr KI und Materialeinsatz
[Musik]
ja Herr Professor Schall wir haben die
Drohnen gerade gesehen und die
Möglichkeiten die künstliche Intelligenz
bietet lassen Sie uns bei dem bei dem
Beispiel gerade bleiben mit dem Drohnen
Angriff ich habe eine Situation die gab
es im Afghanistan Krieg die gibt es
jetzt in der Ukraine eine Gruppe von
Zivilisten ist in einem Supermarkt oder
in einem Restaurant und möglicherweise
sind dort auch feindliche Soldaten
was ist wie zu entscheiden wie würde der
Mensch entscheiden und wie entscheidet
die Drohne und nach welchen ethischen
Kriterien entscheidet die Drohne
wie vorhin schon gesagt es ist eine
Frage der jetzt sage ich doch mal
Programmierung ja es gibt es gibt einen
Standard eine internationale
Standardisierungsorganisation für für
technologiebasierte Entwicklung die
beschäftigt sich tatsächlich mit Ethik
in autonomen Systemen und das ist halt
die zwei Triple
e72021 und hier fragt man sich wie
können wir es schaffen ethische
Überlegungen in die sozusagen in den Bau
und in die
Programmierung sage ich doch mal von von
KI z.B in Drohnen hinein zu bekommen das
heißt man probiert so etwas ähnliches
umzusetzen wie Ethik beides sein man
probiert das was wir wollen bereits in
die Programmierung in den sozusagen das
handlungsreper von Drohnen zu bekommen
und damit sie an das anzupassen was
unsere ethischen Standard sagen wir kurz
auf Engagement der NATO sind und das
wäre eine Möglichkeit dafür Professor
Schall darf ich da kurz einhaken denn
das Problem der Menschheit besteht ja
unter anderem darin dass wir diese
Fragen diskutieren aber gar keine
richtigen Antworten darauf haben also
die Frage ist es moralisch ein Flugzeug
abzuschießen wenn die Insassen dabei
sterben aber dafür werden sich tausende
Menschen in einem Fußballstadion
gerettet diese Fragen stellen wir uns
aber wir haben keine umfassende Antwort
darauf wie sollen wir denn die KI
füttern wenn wir selber nicht wissen
und jetzt stelle ich Ihnen die Frage und
allen anderen auch welchen moralischen
Zwängen und Druck drücken denn
tatsächlich militärische Entscheider
ausgesetzt sind die in solchen
Augenblicken entscheiden müssen also
letzten Endes wir externalisieren das
was wir als Gesellschaft in Bezug auf
unsere Ethik nicht konsensual Wissen auf
diejenigen die unter Entscheidungszwang
in einer entsprechenden militärischen
Situation stehen und die Diskussion über
künstliche Intelligenz macht genau 1 sie
zeigt uns auf wo wir als Gesellschaft
stehen und wofür wir stehen und dass wir
kein Konsens in diesen Fragen haben
zeigt einfach nur dass wir uns teilweise
vor der ethischen Frage drücken was uns
wie viel wert ist sei sozusagen in einem
zehntelverhältnis oder einfach bloß
tatsächlich als intrinsischer Wert und
wenn wir genötigt sind das für Menschen
intuitiv tun oder mit sowas ähnlich wie
ein einer moralischen Intuition
tatsächlich zu formalisieren fällt es
uns unglaublich schwer genau das zu tun
und insofern haben wir es nicht mit
einem Problem der künstlichen
Intelligenz zu tun sondern mit einem
Problem das eigentlich vorgelagert ist
die Frage was sind unsere wirklichen
ethischen Standards und eine Antwort
lautet
das Minimum der Ethik ist das Recht und
das wäre für mich die Genfer Konvention
als etwas auf das sich alle berufen
können eine total spannende Frage in
diesem Zusammenhang kommt an dieser
Stelle von Sven Odendahl über Facebook
werden in einem solchen Szenario auch
mögliche Szenarien zur Friedenslösung
durch die KI mit berücksichtigt und das
ist natürlich insofern spannend weil
natürlich kann man die KI programmieren
dass sie möglichst effizient Krieg führt
aber der Mensch entscheidet ja an
irgendeinem Punkt jetzt ist gerade der
richtige Zeitpunkt um zu verhandeln
können wir auch das der KI beibringen
es gibt ja es gibt ja
weltsimulationsprogramme selbst Welt
simulationski die quasi nicht nur das
militärische Battlefield betrachten
sondern in einem globalen systemischen
Ansatz unterwegs sind so etwas wäre es
wenn man es dann wollte in dem Bereich
in dem ich unterwegs bin also dem
engeren sozusagen verteidigungs- ist
diese Frage nicht wirklich angekommen
ich hätte aber eine andere Deutung
nämlich auf Basis unserer eigenen
Forschung haben wir
sagen wir mal zehn Panzer und wir haben
getestet wie viel Drohnen es braucht von
einem roten Team also einem Gegner um
diese Panzer aus zu löschen
einmal mit und einmal ohne unsere
künstliche Intelligenz Ergebnis war man
braucht ungefähr 6 mal so viel Drohnen
wenn man künstliche Intelligenz
sozusagen erhöhte Ausrüstung hat als
normale mit menschlichen Entscheidung
und meine Antwort lautet dass wir mit
Hilfe von künstlichen Intelligenz und
dem was wir in Deutschland zum Beispiel
an wirkmitteln haben wenn man die
updatet erhöht man die
Abschreckungswirkung dessen was da ist
teilweise in den Faktor drei vier fünf
sechs und das bedeutet dass wir nicht in
eine hochrüstungsspirale kommen und
trotzdem mehr Abschreckung haben und das
wäre für mich schon mal eine Annäherung
daran dass es gar nicht erst zu einem
Krieg kommt ich weiß das ist keine so
schöne Lösung wie die die gefragt wurde
auf Facebook was glaube ich aber es ist
zumindest eine praktikable Möglichkeit
für die politische Praxis
lassen Sie uns noch über ein Beispiel
denken sprechen was schon selbst relativ
viel entscheidet oder mit entscheidet
wenn man das so sagen kann nämlich harpy
können Sie ganz kurz erklären was das
ist und wie das funktioniert
auf dieses Beispiel würde ich gerne in
diesem Augenblick lieber nicht eingehen
dann hacke ich jetzt auch nicht nach
aber vielleicht können Sie den
ZuschauerInnen und zuschauernden zwei
Sätzen nur erklären warum sie darauf
nicht eingehen möchten denn das ist ja
man kann dafür gute Gründe haben aber
vielleicht ist es gut zu wissen warum
das hat so ein bisschen damit zu tun wer
wir sind ja sozusagen im Bereich des
Bundesministeriums der Verteidigung und
zum anderen dass wir natürlich auch
Industriekontakte haben es gibt
bestimmte Bereiche in denen ich dann
einfach lieber keine Stellungnahme geben
würde es gibt Bereiche die sind es gibt
Bereiche die sind nicht für die
öffentlichkeit ähm bestimmt vielleicht
können Sie ja aber weil das einen User
auch interessiert ohne dass sie da jetzt
irgendwie zu weit gehen aber vielleicht
können Sie die Frage beantworten hier
fragt jemand wie viel KI entwickelt die
Bundeswehr selber und was macht die
Rüstungsindustrie z.B Hellsing oder rein
Metall wem gehört das KI Modell dann der
Bundeswehr oder dem Unternehmen
okay das ist eine Frage die ich einfach
beantworten kann die kann ich nun darf
ich auch beantworten
alle alle deutschen Rüstungsunternehmen
Arbeiten an KI Modellen natürlich
Helsing natürlich reinmetall und ähnlich
ist sie sind sehr avanciert und das
Problem ist die Frage nach der sozusagen
Transparenz der KI weil das die KI
Modelle sind ja dann tatsächlich Teil
des Business Plans gehören also in ihrer
in ihrer in ihre Programmierung und
ähnlichen dementsprechenden Unternehmen
ähm das kann für
Irritationen sorgen und auch für
sicherheitspolitische Herausforderungen
deshalb gibt es einige Überlegungen die
dahin gehen dass man so etwas ähnliches
hat wie KI Modelle die komplett gekauft
werden und dann von der Bundeswehr von
unseren eigenen Programmierern und
IT-Spezialisten angepasst werden so dass
wir quasi dann eigene inhouse Lösungen
haben die auch genuin schließlich von
der Bundeswehr genutzt werden das hat
vor und Nachteile es hat den Nachteil
dass man mehr Ressourcen braucht es hat
den Vorteil dass dass man dann erst mit
sozusagen singulären Systemen zu tun hat
denn eine Gefahr die vorhin auch genannt
wurde ist sobald man weiß wie unsere
entscheidungssysteme funktionieren es
muss nicht gehackt werden muss sozusagen
muss
entscheidungsalgorithmen kennen weiß man
wie wir reagieren werden und damit sind
Überraschungsmomente weg weil man ja
berechenbar wird und das wäre die größte
Katastrophe und hier haben wir es also
mit einem mit einem sozusagen
mit einer Balance zu tun zwischen
unterschiedlichen Zielen die man im
Augenblick noch in der Diskussion hat
so viel kann ich sagen
ja das war doch das war doch schon sehr
viel vielen herzlichen Dank dafür eine
Frage noch wir haben zu Beginn der
Sendung in die Ukraine geblickt das
würde ich jetzt gegen Ende der Sendung
gerne auch noch mal tun
inwiefern profitiert die Ukraine konkret
von künstlicher Intelligenz was die
Munition angeht sie haben das schon mal
angerissen aber vielleicht können wir es
noch mal kurz vertiefen
Munition ist ja eines der ganz großen
sozusagen Lieferprobleme für die Ukraine
und
die Ukraine hat in den letzten Monaten
feuerleitsysteme bekommen die ki-basiert
sind und diese feuerleitsysteme die KI
basiert sind erhöhen die Zielgenauigkeit
und reduzieren auch die Zeit zwischen
sozusagen den Befehl dass man sich auf
etwas fokussiert im Abschluss und
dementsprechend ist die
Nutzung der knappen Ressourcen Munition
deutlich besser geworden also mit
anderen Worten hier hat die Ukraine
deutlich profitiert davon dass sie KI in
diesem Feuer das System hat
eine Frage zum Abschluss über Facebook
fragt Wolfgang Müller oder sagt er
Menschen die sowas erfinden sind hoch
gefährlich und er selbst sagt ich halte
KI für sehr gefährlich die Frage an Sie
ist KI beim militärischen Einsatz
gefährlich oder
macht es Krieg so weit man das überhaupt
sagen kann
besser weil man damit weniger zivile
Ziele
Mitleidenschaft zieht weil weniger
Menschen sterben weil die Soldaten
besser geschützt werden weil Munition
effizienter eingesetzt wird macht KI
Kriege besser wenn es dann überhaupt
Kriege geben muss
alle Punkte die sie genannt haben
sprechen dafür dass man künstliche
Intelligenz einsetzt wenn es tatsächlich
zu einem heißen Krieg kommt
hundertprozentig
dass die größte Herausforderung für mich
besteht darin dass das passiert was die
NATO bereits 2022 immer drin gesagt hat
nämlich dass wir gar nicht mehr zwischen
Krieg und Frieden differenzieren weil
wir uns in einem permanenten Zustand
einen braustufen Zustand befinden indem
wir Hybrid angegriffen werden
insbesondere im Bereich der
Desinformation der übrigen das
Information oder das was man kommt
vorfährt nennen kann also die
Beeinflussung unserer
meinungsöffentlichkeit mit dem
dezidierten Ziel unsere Demokratie zu
destabilisieren unsere außenpolitischen
Entscheidungen zu verändern und letzten
Endes damit die demokratische Qualität
und das Leben hier weniger sicher zu
machen und weniger freiheitlich und das
ist die größte Herausforderung für mich
dass wir uns eigentlich in einem Zustand
sozusagen Chris angegriffen Seins
befinden ohne dass wir als Gesellschaft
wirklich ein Bewusstsein dafür haben wo
wir überall potenziell manipuliert
werden auf der anderen Seite könnte auch
das Gefühl immer aufmerksam sein zu
müssen für die Fakes in Audio im
Videobereich oder ähnliches ich könnte
die ganze Zeit sozusagen in russischer
Troll sein ja der hier eingespeist wird
wir können so keine Demokratie führen
das heißt wir müssen grundlegend anders
denken wie man vor dem Hintergrund von
Meinungsmanipulation und der Nutzung von
künstlichen Intelligenz durch
gegnerische Staaten autokratische Natur
Demokratie anders denkt dass sie
resilienter wird also mit anderen Worten
wir müssen die Art wie wir unsere
Demokratie denken neu denken und das
werden wir quasi angegriffen werden und
das macht für mich die größte
Herausforderung aus der Krieg ist nicht
nur in der Ukraine die Reparationen sind
dauerhaft auch in unserer Gesellschaft
eine große Herausforderung für uns alle
für die ganze Welt vielen Dank Herr
Professor Schall dass Sie bei uns in der
Sendung waren und so viele Fragen von
unseren Userinnen und Usern beantwortet
haben und danke schön dafür dass sie
hier waren herzlichen Dank es hat mich
sehr gefreut danke für die tollen Fragen
das gebe ich sehr gerne weiter an unsere
Community vielen Dank an Sie und euch
dass ihr so fleißig mit kommentiert und
gefragt habt und wenn ich hier in den
Chat gucke dann stelle ich fest dass sie
auch viel diskutiert wird und es eine
abschließende Frage auf dieses eine
abschließende Antwort auf die Frage ob
KI denn nun eine Superwaffe ist oder
nicht wie wir es auch bei uns im Titel
dir gestellt haben die Frage dass man
diese Antwort so schnell nicht finden
kann vielen Dank dass ihr mit dabei wart
und bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss